the raiders looked to erase last
sunday's disappointment with a great
performance against the falcons as john
treach reports
you can learn from a loss but not dwell
on defeat
the raiders had the chiefs chasing they
were going to sweep the season series
gain momentum in the playoff push
and then that maddening mahomes made all
the glory go away
you know a mistake on the back end and
he just you know made us pay
you know he's a great quarterback he
makes plays like that so
you know for us we just got to stay
solid and firm on our execution
and you know finish our games not all
was lost in sunday's soul-crushing
defeat the raiders prove they can play
with anyone
under any circumstance you know we got a
long way to go
but we're getting progress we're making
signs on offense and we're showing some
things on defense
we just got to play a lot better
together this week's matchup in atlanta
tantalizes with quarterback talent again
featuring
derek carr and the falcons matt ryan
they call him maddie ice for a reason
when the game's on the line at the end
of the game he's
he's got a way of bringing his team back
and
you know i i think a lot of our
quarterback obviously i'm not going to
compare them the raiders are six
and four with six games to go so much
potential
potential means you haven't done it yet
of course coach
reporting from las vegas john treach